[Musique]
et si certains masquant tissus faits
maison n'était en fait pas assez
efficaces contre le virus
avec l'arrivée des variants le haut
conseil de santé publique recommande de
ne plus utiliser certains masques
il est désormais obligatoire dans les
transports comme dans les commerces
bavarois le masque ffp2 imposé pour
mieux lutter contre la propagation du
variant angles est une protection vendu
3 euros l'unité
les personnes qui se sont fabriqué leurs
propres masques y compris en suivant les
normes afnor sur internet devrait
basculer vers des masques plutôt
industriels dont les normes de
filtration correspondent au moins à 90 %
en fait me servent à rien ces masques
alors qu'on nous a dit vous des masques
à la maison non il faut pas dire ça
alors qu'est ce que veut dire cet avis
du haut conseil scientifique
si je vous contaminer je ne le ferai pas
vous voyez bien gdaxi ma manière de le
faire
il y à un aérosol est l'aérosol n'est
pas totalement filtré c'est sûr qu'il
est mieux filtrer par les ffp2 mieux
parler fp&a est moins bien encore par
les matchs continuent dans un avis
transmis à la direction générale de la
santé
le haut conseil de la santé publique le
recommande un format sont pas encore
publiés mais confirmée par deux de ses
membres
ça c'est la base surgit cas classique
que je porte j'ai pris pour vous a fait
p2 qu'on utilise dans le domaine médical
mais pour des gestes précise gestao
d'exposition mais je sais pas si vous
l'avez déjà essayé et bien c'est très
confortable
moi si on m'oblige à mettre un masque
ffp2 je vous dis hein je le prends jean
fait un énorme feu de joie parce que le
stop faut arrêter le délire total
ça veut dire que les masques comporte au
quotidien encore une façon d'avoir
évolué sur ce qu'on appelle grand public
probablement qu effectivement en lieu
clos je pense qu'il va plus falloir les
porter à l'extérieur à mon avis ça pose
aucun problème de parcours de porter des
masques grand public
on est toujours plus tôt
invitant que coercitif sur l'ensemble de
ces sujets mais on va évidemment passer
l'information de manière de manière
forte et peut-être qu'on arriverait
quelque chose d'obligatoire
au bout de quelques jours sert qu'on va
tuer le pays on va tuer le pays
troisième confinement couvre-feu des
masses pour les gamins 6 ans à l'école
ce qui est un visa europe plus de 160
études ainsi que les rapporte
il s'appelle ses 19 c'est ali c'est un
anglais il faut lire un petit peu
l'anglais donc avec un petit peu des
deux vous y arriverez est donc l'élément
essentiel si vous prenez les gens pour
les is you say me rappelle de l'huma
tarif est divisé par deux notamment en
ehpad et notamment chez les sujets
fragiles se sont donné je ne parle pas
d'opinion
la france reçoit les mêmes doses
proportionnellement que les autres pays
et nous sommes
25e sur 27 les derniers les derniers
pour 100 habitants pour 100 habitants au
nombre de vaccinations
comment cela se fait-il monsieur
méprisant et endémiques lui donc je ne
serai pas et ils me traitent du midi que
je fais de l'humour je me fais de
l'humour je vais jouer citer les études
que j'ai lu dans la société française de
pharmacologie je cite mes sources et et
toutes ces études sont sources et aucune
ne dit que ça marche voilà c'est un
débat dans lesquels évidemment on peu
difficile mais s'il a ses propres études
donc les siennes sont bonnes et celle
des autres sont mauvaises qu'est-ce que
ça devient une secte quoi c'est ainsi
c'est une opération de masse qui
concerne le monde entier
les capacités de production sont à bloc
et la france en profitera au même rythme
que les autres
cc d'affoler la réponse idéale serait
d'avoir aujourd'hui assez de vaccins
pour vacciner tous les français je
dirais le monde entier ce n'est pas le
cas la production des vaccins dans le
monde à travers les différents
fabricants ne permet pas cela cela
permet donc je les dis 2,5 milliards 2,5
millions de doses disponibles en janvier
qui seront toutes utilisées il n'y a pas
de stock caché cette image que
de edouard balladur voilà qui dont le
procès s'ouvre aujourd'hui dans la
sphère dit karachi soyez passionné dans
tout ce que vous faites mais rappelez
vous toujours que la violence n'est
jamais la réponse et ne sera jamais
justifié